petra en dot com slash debug my
driver my library in pictures
der or fifteen hundred title the plebs
so far check it out great news for
those who
demonstrate the de in the groin on climate
change march
those who participated in the margins for
science two weeks and  ziggo
congress is i nori donald trump and is
decided to increase
funding for size guide you in advance
copy of the 2017
viscoheel budget some of the items that
will be found in this budget
the river trillion dollars for the
national institutes of health
1907 trillion dollars for  nasa
series 7 million vote for nassau's
eldritch programs 7 2 5 trillion for the
national science foundation from just
over trillion dollars for the us
geological survey three and a half million
for noah the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration and 17
million dish for radio bull energy
and clean energy research  which is already there
increases the most notably dieser
strong contrast both donald trump
actually like  this budget is expected to
pass on may 5
we dit is het niet de campaign team
proposals to a science program sam als
across the board and glass with fred de
sync with programs laikipia
die warm en de projection agency dior eau
de parfum energy de gaiwan in dat
apartment in think i find i hiss
and edge new
every single one of those things and
mentioned in the list of various the
download of was too cold for 2 tens
this is your site freddy be careful not to
be hyperbole can de show this is one  of
the most in die science administrations
and peace and history
this is to a pinyon just based on
what they wanted you to find the many
of these programs this is shine
completely com bubble in an ipod racing
that is trees and everything badly gravel
republic in fulfillment  syncro summer the
budget sporadically private agencies
and programs ya imam inazuma fixed price
my coming and sab germany [ __ ] with the
willing to supporting
crisis for i think kleenair q  ueen water
annual energy costs on how
in society they get skype controversial
yes en wie
so de seeming conflict piet friend
ramses budget priorities and congress
[ __ ]
de budget what silence when he ten
budget for tampons de career de staf
met silent for prior approval by congress
maybe  this is assigned the congress
would be more reasonable and funding
science in the future but would wait for
a group of consumers critic
so and the new the super major die the
best budget and certain en men die
such as this need to be made for
democrats
republic  in seven new interests and
sharing down the cabernet
right now symmetry of the disaster how
switch level de dea dia is accenture
jan de government anytime soon and this
sort of help attendants become dry
congress controls de funding na de
presidenten presidenten mix
recommendations on the budget especially  the
melee the president ashraf of congresses
proposed budget so
democrats the sam backbone they did
somet  hung good hereby single you have
english as some of you want but more
broadly speaking on a
nose twitched with water that everywhere
conventional budget try your lies in
the united states
louis elizabeth i knew what the democracy
and been able to go do not see more
kompels  man and smash usb cable to get
some kind stations and can him
olivia gamers who trump in europa
league kind otherwise your bios hdd the
stage scenes is very simple week is the
headsets discovered resetting the feeling
the american health care act was
problem topless work am  no need
we speak house of jamie jamie and i
since the edges minority don't know in
republic instagram die etc in order de
de vitamins i democrats at
storyboarding in favor of fair and i
think that must be a popstar jennifer
connelly tank democrats today
necessarily redes  kan feel like you a
and running on the clock trine 2 sometimes
for 2010 en 2012 comes around
do you think that of the obamacare
review
reversible
jube  l love that obamacare work you will
have before of your team
i find in have a in the press qor'an
i've courted time believing that will be
called it really hard to get the gringo
de republic in party en de centrist
in republic  a few let come
together
the freedom cactus is a love our it did
get repeal who absolutely frank and and
needed many times who it political lira
inhabitants homes favor of best and
just by the fact that if people start
losing their health care some will still
figure  out would be blame obama
windows choose nike of the price and the
anymore
willing lasts think about people
will lose your health care [ __ ]
football goal trump and the republic an
electric fiber the canoe or via and who
will him called cathy society and my na
hoof  to think
well or mickey war in the point to point
udall obamacare is at shampoos and sam
measures more popular de niteworks
republic and proposals herder direction
of the two led's immensely 17% and
eq  uipo people about the provisions
that's where you have significant
support at can just be something
hessenpoort van mamas teacher minute
could help
remember background check scampi and
trolls vol background check on can
purchases
ej percent i think there was definitely you
that guess chewing gum care
so this  week is the country support
something that minutes i could him what is
that is struben towards queen mary's the
fence where is chains love president
china s health care bill that want the
strings values ​​can nest
singular butter without na excuse 3 the
stereo claptraps want the news  media
suny stony for the for your house of
hellebaut at house boat on the latest
innovation of the replace with whom you
front fork rst this episode dave a task
my show is made possible in strawberry
warby parker eyeglasses warby parker
with only the driving and which
advertising on  right wing conspiracy
website
bright bar holding the rest off and you can
get the free 5d highline v  an warby
parker
check out your glasses and used and i'm
not wearing contactlens is istar dit met
de free enhonden
well these are the five per se bottles you
see which would you like us and them
back and which everyone you back group
for your  prescription
into a like this week there is an action
show the glass is the other people
and then you have the cylon the spatula me
and aj glassdoor die eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
the keeper price is very very high of
over 300 everything  prescription glasses with
warby parker discharges my the fogbox
mind has taught in nutrition lenses and
for every pair solden they give her to
someone in the short ride 5 press and
support the this talk a show through the
warby parker trial that come forward
heavy
gbps